das problem ist im kanzleramt das sagte
anton hofreiter vor wenigen tagen in
richtung olaf scholz also in richtung
des bundeskanzlers der im gegensatz zum
grünen politiker keine schweren waffen
liefern möchte und damit einen schönen
guten morgen herr hofreiter guten morgen
scholz hat sich gestern geäußert und
gesagt er habe die deutsche
rüstungsindustrie jetzt gebeten zu sagen
was sie liefern könne jetzt gibt es eine
liste ukraine kann bestellen wir also
deutschland bezahlt hat das kanzleramt
das problem jetzt verstanden
es ist ein schritt in die richtige
richtung aber das problem ist die
offensive hat bereits begonnen in der
ost ukraine und deshalb muss man es
versuchen so schnell wie irgendwie
möglich zu liefern und auch die idee um
das osteuropäische mittelosteuropäischen
partner von uns liefern und wir deren
material ersetzen ist gut aber wird
nicht ausreichen war nämlich nach und
nach ist das gesamte sowjetische und
alte russische material zerschossen und
sowie putin drauf ist so verbrecherisch
wieder krieg geführt wird müssen wir als
trauriger weise darauf einstellen dass
dennoch viele monate dauert also sagen
sie die unterstützung der ukraine mit
den gerade erwähnten waffenlieferungen
reicht ihnen erst mal nicht welche
schweren waffen wollen sie ganz konkret
liefern
ich bin wie gesagt ein militärexperte
auch wenn ich mich tief ein gelesen habe
und deswegen finde ich das also etwas
spekulativ aber wir wissen was die
ukraine haben will und ich finde es
ehrlich gesagt da etwas
paternalistisches dem ukrainischen
militär das seit vielen wochen an
heldenhaften widerstand leistet zu sagen
ihr könnt damit nicht umgehen und sich
sagen sie wünschen artillerie sie
wünschen oder panzer und wo wir die
liefern können sollten wir die liefern
sie wünschen auch gepanzerte transporter
alles ist möglich alles ist zum teil
auch bei der rüstungsindustrie möglich
und deshalb muss jetzt schnell passieren
und woher wissen sie dass das alles
möglich ist und dass wir das alles haben
denn die bundeswehr selbst sagt
eigentlich dass sie das alles nicht hat
und nicht kann auch nicht so schnell und
das ist alles ausbildung braucht
erstens wie gesagt dass mit der
ausbildung ich glaubte im ukrainischen
militär ist sehr bewusst
dass man menschen an waffen ausbilden
muss deshalb muss man umso schneller
liefern und bedenken sie zum beispiel
rheinmetall sagt selbst dass bei ihnen
der ganze reihe von japans und stehen
die immer in sehr kurzer zeit liefern
könnte und deshalb lasst uns das einfach
schlicht victory das heißt nicht sagen
darf ich da ganz konkret nachfragen weil
das ist ja gerade die aktuelle
diskussion der ukrainische botschafter
hier in deutschland wenig hat das
gestern abend im heute-journal gefordert
diese 100 marder panzer die bei der
bundeswehr im moment benutzt werden um
ausbildungen durchzuführen da sagen sie
dies schicken wir die können wir in die
ukraine es stehen wie gesagt auch circa
70 marder panzer bei rheinmetall und
deshalb marder panzer die wir gerade
nicht aktuell dringend benötigen
schicken wir an die ukraine und ersetzen
sie durch innerhalb weniger wochen bei
circa 20 bis 30 die übrigen er einigen
monaten dann aufzuarbeiten panzerbauer
rheinmetall so was ist zum beispiel
vorstellbar und des weiteren muss hat
deutschland auch deutlich mehr tun in
richtung energie im bus selbst
frankreich forderten
lass mir dass energie embargo mal weg
bleiben aktuell bei den waffen die
stehen so ohne weiteres nicht zur
verfügung sagte hier vor einer stunde
der stellvertretende generalinspekteur
generalleutnant markus laubenthal waren
wir mal kurz gemeinsam rein
[Musik]
wir hätten keine möglichkeit mehr auf
eventualitäten zu reagieren und das für
die die verteidigungsfähigkeit doch
erheblich schwächen zum zweiten muss man
sagen dass dieses waffensystem maler
eben ein system es muss in der
gesamtheit also mit den lenkraketen die
dazugehören mit den entsprechenden
handwaffen mit der dazugehörigen
munition für die maschinen kanonen
versorgt war sein und es muss technisch
kriegs tauglich eingesetzt werden können
und das setzt eine gewisse ausgenommen
voraus es ist also nicht so dass der der
da kennt oder irgendein schützenpanzer
kennt dann diese fahrzeuge auch bedienen
kann beziehungsweise jedes andere
bedient hat
also herr hofreiter ob jetzt die 70 oder
die 100 völlig egal
bedienen könnte die das ukrainische
militär nicht wenn wir dem zweit
ranghöchsten soldaten deutschlands
glauben wollen ich hatte ehrlich gesagt
immer wieder für interessant eine
militär des seit sieben wochen einer
übermacht standhält zu erklären was sie
kann und was sie nicht kann ich
vertrauter ehrlich gesagt im
ukrainischen militär wenn sie sagen ja
sie wollen die und sie werden in der
lage sein die leute auszubilden nächster
punkt ist es ist richtig denen jetzt
russisches und sowjetisches material zu
liefern das können sie gleich einsetzen
ich war in der ukraine da hat man mehr
exakt sie hätten gern dass westlichen
material jetzt damit sie eben genau die
zeit haben ihre soldaten an diesem
material zu trainieren die haben nämlich
sogar verständnis dafür und das halte
ich auch für absolut richtig dass wir
alles tun um nicht direkt konfliktpartei
zu werden und deshalb sagen sie uns
liefert jetzt das material dann haben
auch des westlichen material dann haben
wir zeit unsere soldaten selbst dran
auszubilden wenn das russische und
sowjetische material kaputt geschossen
ist und das hat eine hohe logik die
haben wie gesagt sogar verständnis dafür
dass wir kein gas embargo machen das
problem hat für deutschland ist dass wir
bei den sanktionen bremsen bei den
waffenlieferungen bremsen und damit die
gefahr droht dass der krieg sich immer
länger hinzieht und je länger sich
dieser krieg hinzu und je näher putin
einem sieg kommt desto größer ist die
gefahr dass dieser krieg sich ausweitet
dass weitere länder überfallen werden
und wieder dann am ende in einen
erweiterten de facto dritten weltkrieg
rutschen und deshalb müssen jetzt alles
tun um die ukraine zu unterstützen sagt
anton hofreiter von den grünen vielen
herzlichen dank für das gespräch heute